Coughing, sneezing, aches and pains: all normal symptoms of the dreaded flu.
But did you know you can actually have no symptoms at all?
A new study out of England found that about three-quarters of infected people...
...showed no signs of the seasonal flu or swine flu in recent years,...
...potentially making the spread of the virus all the more likely.
To get the results, researchers looked at data during the winter flu seasons...
...between 2006 and 2011, including the 2009 outbreak of swine flu.
The results, published in The Lancet,...
...showed about 18 percent of people without a vaccine got the virus,...
...but only 23 percent of those people actually developed symptoms.
Fewer than one in five people were sick enough to see a doctor or stay home from work.
That's not really getting the flu though, is it?
Well, it's not like any flu I've ever had...
...or at least one I knew I had.